Republican voters in Wyoming
resoundingly rejected Liz Cheney and
when she speaks her old colleagues on
the hill they just roll their eyes so
her constituency now consists of a few
journalists some never trumpers and the
old Bush Cheney Perpetual War
Coalition yet a publisher still gave her
money to write a book which means she'll
be an unwelcome guest in your home if
you turn on CBS this Sunday people who
say well if he's elect did it's not that
dangerous because we have all of these
checks and balances uh don't fully
understand the extent to which the
republicans in Congress today um have
been co-opted one of the things that we
see happening today is sort of a a
sleepwalking into uh dictatorship in the
United States wow sleepwalking into
dictatorship how poetic did she write
that line herself John Dickerson fell
asleep in that interview I think all
right just one the just like the Biden
White House the GOP old guards are in
complete freakout mode over the stay
power of Donald Trump it's driving them
all mad and one of the most unhinged op
ads and I've read a lot of them lately
was published in the Washington Post
this week and in it Uber Warhawk Robert
Kagan smears not only Trump with a tired
old Hitler line how many times can we
read that but anyone who might think of
working for him writing a trump
dictatorship is increasingly inevitable
it will be filled with people who will
not need explicit instruction from Trump
any more than Hitler's local gas needed
instruction in such circumstances people
work toward the furer which is to say
they anticipate his desires and seek
favor through acts they think will make
him
happy Trump trump derangement syndrome
is real these people are sick they need
help joining me now is telsey gabard Fox
News contributor and former Hawaii
Congressman telsey like I used to have
Robert um Kagan on my old radio show at
the beginning of the Iraq War and is not
a dumb person he's a smart person but
how ironic is it that they're the ones
who push legislation like the Patriot
Act that gave the government a way to
infringe on our civil liberties and
they're saying that Trump is the
dictator in Waiting
Here the irony doesn't stop there the
things that he that he outlined in his
incredible long and difficult to read
oped along with things that Liz Chen is
saying they're warning us of of Trump's
reelection being being a dictatorship in
where he will do all of these things
like turn the Department of Justice
against political opponents use the IRS
to go after those who oppose his agenda
the list goes on on the the thing is
that's exactly what the Biden Harris
Administration is doing against
President Donald Trump and against those
they view as their political opponents
but the thing that really bothered me
the most about kagan's oped and many
others who continue to warn the country
that Donald Trump is going to be like a
modern-day Hitler is that they're also
the kinds of people who and we hear this
all the time people say gosh if back in
the day if only one person had the
courage to stop Hitler to take him out
before he rose to power then we would
have saved millions of lives well this
is what they're essential this is a
message inviting violence TSA you're
saying they're inviting someone to take
a shot at Trump this is what is so
dangerous they're they're sending a
message to a rogue actor alone wolf
saying hey we need someone to save our
country from this modern day Hitler
likee person and that is that is what
should alarm every single American this
is not how the United States of America
uh is this is not who we are and yet
this is what these people in positions
of Power are doing in abusing their
power and undermining our democracy
because in their minds The end justifies
the means I I I I am terrified for our
country right now given that type of
rhetoric I mean unlike the left we don't
believe in censoring people's speech but
by doing what they're doing and saying
what they're saying they talk about dog
whistles that's a dog whistle to
violence it is if it's Hitler is in the
wa isn't waiting then you've got to stop
Hitler Hitler can't you know so they
know what they're doing tula and I think
they can't win on the issues it's
obvious they're they're not winning on
any of the issues so this is where they
are do you anticipate violence in the
streets this coming election year given
where they're going well th this is this
is what I'm so concerned about Laura is
exactly what we're talking about here
and why it's so incumbent upon us As
Americans not not Democrats Independence
Republicans but for us as Americans to
take to heart uh the stand that we need
to take to tell these people and it's
not just the establishment Democrats it
is them but it is also these neocons
like Liz Cheney and Robert Kagan who are
who are Fanning these Flames that could
push us to that point absolutely and and
we need to tell them we will not stand
for it and we will not fall for it I
mean Robert Kagan would still have us
back in Afghanistan I mean he's still
waiting for the surge to work all right
telsy thank you great to see you hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else